ومعي الآن
المتحدث الدولي باسم جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي
المقدم ريتشارد هيشت
أخبرني ببعض الأشياء التي كنتم
تفعلونها حول غزة ولكن أيضًا أه في
جنوب لبنان بين عشية وضحاها، لذلك كان هناك
تقارب للحدود الآن
إسرائيل المناطق الحدث الذي
بدأ في القدس امتد إلى غزة
وحماس وإلى لبنان، لذلك
يرجع ذلك أساسًا إلى الأحداث التي حدثت ومرة
أخرى نحن في أوقات متقلبة للغاية أه منذ
ليلتين حدث وبدأ رجل المعبد الرد
من غزة  الذي
يحاول التصعيد مع الكثير من
شبكات التواصل الاجتماعي في هذه المنطقة
وبدأوا في إطلاق الصواريخ بعد
ذلك بدأت بعض الفصائل الفلسطينية في
لبنان وفي مقدمتها حماس أيضًا في
قتال إسرائيل، لذلك كان لدينا مثل
ساحة متعددة مع خصم رئيسي واحد وهو
القدرة الفلسطينية أو نقول أه إنه
وقت متقلب للغاية، من الواضح أننا رأينا
الليلة الماضية ما نسمعه اليوم
هو أن إسرائيل تستدعي بعض
جنود الاحتياط على وجه التحديد في الدفاع الجوي
وكذلك في القوات الجوية، هل يمكنك أن تخبرنا
كم عددهم ولماذا تقوم بهذه
الخطوة الآن؟  لن أخوض في الأرقام
ولكني سأخبرك أننا مستعدون
لأية تطورات يمكنك فهمها
من اللغة التي يتحدث بها هذا الحدث
والتي نريد تخفيفها،
أعني أن هناك عطلة
نهاية أسبوع حساسة للغاية مقبلة مع عيد الفصح.  يتماشى شهر رمضان وعيد
الفصح ونتطلع
إلى أمل عطلة نهاية أسبوع هادئة
على الرغم من تعرضنا لهجوم آخر مباشرة
بعد الصلاة في القدس في
وادي الأردن ولكننا نتطلع
إلى وقف التصعيد، هل تشعرون بذلك على الإطلاق؟
هل تعتقد أن هناك فرصة
لخفض التصعيد في الوقت الحالي أم أنك ترى أن
الأمر متقلب للغاية كما تقول، هل
ترى أن هناك احتمالية أن
ينفجر هذا الأمر إلى شيء أكبر
خاصة الآن عندما تتعامل
مع  جبهتين، أنت في جنوب لبنان
وهنا في غزة أيضًا، ومرة ​​أخرى،
هناك لغة تحدثنا بها،
وكنا نركز بشدة على الأشياء التي
كانت تهددنا على وجه التحديد،
وهناك أيضًا صواريخ من الشمال وأيضًا
صواريخ من غزة، ومرة ​​أخرى نحن
يحاولون الآن الحفاظ على العبادة وإبقاء عطلة
نهاية الأسبوع مفتوحة لأنه
وقت مقدس جميع المعابر من يهودا
والسامرة مفتوحة أيضًا من غزة هناك
أشخاص يأتون وإذا كان الوضع هادئًا
فسيتم الرد عليه بالهدوء كان هناك
هجوم أيضًا في الضفة الغربية  اليوم
قتلت شقيقتين إسرائيليتين
تعرضت سيارتهما لإطلاق النار، هل يمكنك أن تخبرنا
قليلاً عن ذلك وكيف يمكن أن
يلعب ذلك أيضًا دورًا في هذا
الحدث الغادر الذي يندرج في سلسلة من
الأحداث التي شهدناها في الأشهر القليلة الماضية
في هذا البناء الكبير ومرة ​​أخرى،
كان القاصر اليهودي على مدى العام ونصف العام الماضيين غير مستقر للغاية ومتقلب للغاية
22 رصاصة رجل كان
متمسكًا بسيارة مع عائلة
تسافر يوم الجمعة، ولم يرغبوا في
القيام بمهماتهم المعتادة  وقتل
سيدتين لدي عائلة وهناك
أنثى ثالثة أخرى تقاتل من أجل
حياتها بينما نتحدث